what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing our
discussions on x-men disassembled the
return of x-men made great and in the
last video we had talked about how
Warren Worthington had basically been
like transformed into arc angel or I
guess transfer him back in the arc
angels so to be honest here when it
comes to arc angel he's more like a
holdover from fans who remember him from
back in the day but he's not like a
powerful character it's not like ain't a
Warren Worthington became Archangel and
then basically became God it was nothing
like that he's just a holdover from from
people who love the x-men comics back in
the 90s people who loved things like X B
in the animated series and so on and so
forth as a guys were reading x-men for
25 years he was never really important
but he was never really that big of a
deal
at least not to me anyway but but again
like this kind of fight that takes place
between Magneto and an angel honestly
it's kind of a fight that like person
and in in Rosenberg and Kelly they all
kind of like nip in the bud and the
reason why is because under normal
circumstances Warren would be useless
against against magneto because you're
talking about a guy with metal wings
fighting the master of magnetism now the
fight kind of breaks out and it sort of
unfolds magneto basically blocks the
shots of of Warren and then essentially
says like you guys have brought this all
on yourselves you guys are all doomed
now the other half of this is that with
Warren he's no Ally here and this is
kind of a return to familiarity and the
reason why was because after Warren
became archangel and then kind of went
forward eventually he was released from
the control of apocalypse but it was
kind of like an existential crisis right
like now that he's had this huge shift
and is this huge paradigm shift and who
he is it was like who is Warren was she
about what does he stand for all that
kind of good stuff so he kind of left
the x-men for like a wild in this same
scenario it's kind of unfolding again
this is sort of throwing comics back to
the 1990s and saying well now he's kind
of out there on his own angel stands
alone now he's really kind of his thing
so he's not an ally of the x-men but
he's not an enemy of the x-men he'll
never go back to the way he was before
at least that's kind of the indication
as this going on here and so from that
point you know the x-men basically say
okay fine if you're not gonna do
anything for us then at least show us
where x-men is operating out up and so
that's something basically give them the
location now of course this fight this
this little bit of a conflict goes
exactly the way you would expect in a
sense it like the main x-men roster
shows up and then you've got what's left
of the horsemen of life who are just
kind of like hey you guys need to leave
and so on and so forth this begins to
shift when x-man Nate gray himself shows
up and this is kind of an important
thing is because again Nate gray in this
scenario is far more powerful than he
used to be they can't stop him there's
no way they possibly could because his
power is just on a whole different level
not only that we end up finding out in
this
of an oculus conversation that Jean Grae
had with an older woman at a coffee shop
it was kind of this discussion of like
hey like is the earth worth saving and
it was more or less of a conversation
between a mutant and an on meeting the
difference here is that x-man I
basically seize control of this old
woman's body and was actually the one
having a conversation with Jean and what
he got from that is Earth basically
sucks like Earth is a cesspool and it's
really crappy if you're a mutant and so
this was kind of an interesting thing
because the stance of x-man here is I'm
doing this for the greater good and it's
not really wrong this world you live in
basically sucks
you guys believe it's great but it's not
as great as you think it is you know
that because every day of your life is
lived for fear of like the government
just turning against you or Humanity
trying to wipe you out
unless you're the Avengers or the
Fantastic Four or any myriad of
superhero teams out there that are not
mutants then life is okay but if you're
if you're a mutant then life sucks and
it's kind of crazy here because the idea
of Nate is to basically say like we're
going to fix that if humanity won't fix
itself then I will fix humanity before
no again this is kind of a cool thing
because it leads to a little bit like at
least a little introspection on my
humanity side like as the reader it kind
of gives us a little bit of a a little
bit of a mode to ask the question like
is x-man right like if the earth is
going to pod and humanity won't fix it
and somebody can come along who can't
fix it then is it okay for them to take
control from humanity's hands and my my
answer would be yes like humanity had
its chance and it couldn't get it
together
so x-man is like okay fine if you can't
get it together I'll get it together for
you you had your chance it's really a
cynical perspective but it's a cool
perspective nonetheless because when the
x-men make their move on on Nate gray
then like he immediately just
incapacitates them all with them all
being incapacitated and just floating
there in the air unable to use their
powers or at least not able to use them
effectively it shows just how outmatched
they really are the x-men can do
something as simple as just float them
in the air and leave them there and
there's nothing they can do to stop him
now of course this leads to the arrival
of the what are basically the new
mutants kind of showing up here and it's
interesting because when it came to the
new mutants in Marvel Comics and again
it's really these guys kind of
continuing on like the old Chris
Claremont era of storytelling when Chris
Claremont originally loves to do mutants
and they kind of stood alongside the
x-men the uncanny x-men what you got was
a sort of youthful perspective of the
world new mutants who looked at the
world and they saw it in a way where
like they saw it like children do this
is what the world can be not what the
world is when he looked at the uncanny
x-men
they were kind of jaded for the most
part like there was kind of like yeah
man the world kind of sucks and we're
just taking it one day at a time but
with the new mutants showing up here
they do with the uncanny x-men
not the x-men showed up and were
immediately just like okay so you have
to stop Nate gray and like it
immediately came to blows then you
didn't show up they say we just want to
talk like we want to know what you're
about the problem with this is that
they're dealing with Nate grey and at
the end of the day no matter what
discussion may happen Nate Gray's
resolve is steeled and so what this
means is it's not going anywhere and the
only person who really seems to realize
this is Legion and so in this moment
Legion channels what I assume is the
organist and then in turn just like
sends everybody to what appears to be
the Age of Apocalypse so you basically
have the new means and you've got x-man
who are whisked away to this this
alternate reality now again that's the
kind of power that Legion possesses
Legion possesses the ability to pull off
all these crazy things now what this
does is it kind of jumps forward a
little bit and picks up with the
infinites basically in in Chicago
Illinois
now the infinites were the soldiers of
apocalypse farmer correctly and they're
basically the ones who went out and like
captured mutants things like that they
really did more in terms of working
directly with sinister but at the end of
the day they were all agents of
apocalypse anyway but ultimately like
this group basically gets split in half
you know you have the the New Moon's
like three of them who basically go one
direction two more go another and it's
them just trying to make their way in
this world now of course they end up you
know finally strolling across x-man but
we end up finding out that basically
what's happened is like a huge amount of
time has passed and during this time
they've all had to do some pretty shady
things in order to survive now that's
the nature of the Age of Apocalypse
right the Age of Apocalypse was a
universe of testing that apocalypse
essentially set in motion a circumstance
where the earth was put in the most
harsh environment it could possibly be
put in in order to be able to
differentiate between the weak and the
strong now by this point in time
apocalypse has long since been dead
earth is essentially in shambles like
Earth is just in pieces and all over the
place but traveling with Maigret and
going to Chicago what they're doing is
they're looking for the shard of the
m'kraan crystal but the important thing
here is an eight great kana lets his
guard down make great shows up here are
travelling chicago in this universe he
thought he escaped own to find out that
it's just like a terrifying place as
deserts as horrifying as you remembers
it being and that it's a hopeless place
and so when you have them basically
discovering this charge of the m'kraan
crystal only to find out that when they
open it the crystal essentially just
kind of dissipates turns to dust and
falls away that's when you basically
realize like there's no real escape here
Alicia doesn't seem to be one now Nate
gray himself is temporarily
incapacitated when he's thrown inside of
one of these stasis pods and this leads
to a conversation between hosaka and
pixie and when this discussion takes
place between the two of them it's this
I'm sorry hisako's rather this whole
thing kind of unfolds in such a way to
where pixie makes the case that we
basically have like x-men in a
we can form here it's bad form to kick a
guy when he's down but it's not really
bad for him to do that
when he threatens to destroy like
everything you know and love and like
any measure of a father of a husband you
do whatever you have to to keep your
family safe even if that means like
helping somebody else finish with all
their living and in this instance is
literally what it's what what Pixies
saying is like we've got this guy
defeated let's just kill him but if we
if we kill him here and now and we find
a way out of this universe he can't
destroy our own and it's it so it's
actually a pretty legitimate argument
we're literally going to spare hundreds
of thousands if not millions of people
by killing this one guy now it's a small
sacrifice and so we're under normal
circumstances his Sakho probably would
have said no no that's unreasonable like
they're literally in an in this
alternate reality see how bad things can
get and so the response is yeah it's the
smart decision to make and so literally
his psycho like goes to kill x-man Nate
gray and it's kind of crazy to see that
whole thing unfold like like you
wouldn't you would not expect that to
take place now the other half of this
deals with the fight going on in in the
main Marvel Universe itself and again
like it's just kind of the Four Horsemen
of life facing off against you know the
x-men proper and they're defeated quick
fast and in a hurry right I mean there's
not a whole lot of this conflict going
on Kitty Pryde finally shows up she's
basically freed alongside senator Allen
but then the group is met with the
arrival of apocalypse now this is a very
big thing in this group reacts exactly
the way you would expect him to because
of hot gloves is an opportunist in every
single circumstance no matter what's
going on apocalypse will be your ally up
until he's not up until he sees a chance
to implement his plan for world
domination and minerals turning against
you in a heartbeat and that's the nature
of his character it's what he's always
done is one of things that make him such
a cool villain and that's the reason why
the x-men are walking on eggshells here
I'm like well it's Apocalypse okay let's
kill him like let's be done with it now
that one of the big issues here is that
I feel like Britton and Rosenberg and
Kelly really kind of downplay the power
of Apocalypse and the reason why I say
that is because when this happens when
apocalypse kind of makes a response is
saying look there's no reason to argue
here what's basically going on is that
you you essentially have like Legion who
seems to somehow be tied into all of
this
you have like all the children of the
x-men who are in this alternate reality
I guess the young x-men the alternate
reality give that x-men out there none
of you guys can defeat x-man
but like killing legion is the key to
like stranding them there because so
long as Legion is alive because he's the
one that's symptom they're Legion seems
to be the way by which they can come
back so kill Legion and so apocalypse
just like runs up on him too literally
Troi David Haller and the rest of the
x-men respond but the problem with this
is that Jean Grey by herself is able to
basically overpower apocalypse and like
subdue him that should never happen and
the reason why is because just how
powerful he is
I mean maybe apocalypse is just like
then decrease in power over the years in
kind of subtle ways I just haven't
noticed but as far as I'm aware
apocalypse is just like a force of
nature right like he's just a plague
sweeping across the world and the x-men
like a full contingent of the x-men and
x-factor and even the Inhumans even at
their best could not defeat apocalypse
all at the same time he's just that
powerful and that capable so I feel like
this is really really being downplayed
here which is not the worst thing ever
but it does kind of raise some eyebrows
of why they would necessarily go in that
direction now again you know it's just
kind of circumstances on for this just
come to kind of come out of the previous
events where apocalypse was deep Howard
for a time you know the little backup
features and so on and so forth so again
what the direction things are going in
it may just be that apocalypse is not at
his traditional full level of power if
he is that's fine but nonetheless you
know Bishop basically is the one who
kind of comes in tells Betsy Braddock
like use your psychic dagger penetrate
my mind in the mind of David Haller
create a link and put me in David's mind
and that's when you end up finding out
though what's going on here in this
universe that they're in is not actually
the the Age of Apocalypse instead what's
happened here is Legion is literally
pulled him into his own mind that's one
of the things to bear in mind when it
comes to David is his mind is is a
veritable army of personalities I mean
it's it's thousands and thousands of
personalities but he's got his own like
I soon as a zone the universe inside of
his own head and so being yanked into
that like he can change the universe
than anything he wants to
in this instance he knows that x-man
comes from Age of Apocalypse he knows
that universe is the one thing Nate gray
fears the most
and so his response is yank them all
into his mind and then throw them into
what appears to be the Age of Apocalypse
and then just kind of let it go from
there and so with bishops showing up
here stopping his Saco from killing
x-man then the responses will hey like
there's always a better way so on and so
forth yada yada yada you know general
doodle hippie talk and then that turns
into like Nate gray realizing that
because Bishop looks the same as he did
before he arrived in here but this is
not in actual universe that nine months
have not actually passed here only five
minutes has actually passed in the main
Marvel Universe but Nate grey picks up
on that immediately now this is where we
really get to see the power of Nate gray
and the reason is because when you're
talking about so many being pulled into
the mind of Legion I mean it's
essentially just a countdown to when you
die right like you're just biding your
time until like the end of your life
that's really all it is because you're
talking about like one of those powerful
beings in existence with thousands of
nataly's each one having a power of its
own some of which are the same some of
which are different but you would think
x-man Nate gray be yanked into the mind
of legion would be hopelessly to be no
way for an eighth grader to respond to
that and the answer is nope that's not
the case at all because we're David
basically says like you're in my mind
now I can do anything in this room this
is this is this is essentially my
universe I have total control over this
reality the response of x-man is no you
don't either and the reason why is
because what he does is literally take
over the mind of legion in its entirety
seizes control of legions brain seizes
control of all of legions personalities
and then Rhee manifests in the main
Marvel Universe and so what you're
basically dealing with here is insane
this is x-man Nate gray with all of his
powers beyond Omega level telepath and
telekinetic combined with all the powers
of David holler and access to all the
personalities of Legion and all their
powers the guy's a veritable God now oh
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
to the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]